Android studio is evolving rapidly if
you'd like to get a preview of the next
release but don't want to risk your
productivity you can keep two copies of
Android studio installed side-by-side if
you haven't already start by downloading
the stable release from the Android
developer site then head over to tools
at android comm and grab a copy of the
latest canary build install each in two
different locations now of course the
whole point is to keep a stable build on
one and the cutting edge on the other so
open up the preferences on your stable
installation navigate to system settings
and updates and make sure the
automatically check updates checkbox is
checked then select stable now do the
same for your preview installation only
this time select the canary channel from
the update settings you've also got the
option of setting either channel to beta
which is the channel used for release
candidates before they're pushed out
through stable you can change the
channel used for updating your stable or
preview installation at any time in
either case if you encounter a bug use
the help submit feedback menu to file a
bug directly with the Android studio
team you'll be notified of new versions
of Android studio for the relevant
channel on restart or you can force a
check by selecting check for updates at
any time